hello everyone uh thanks for joining
this session this is the last session of
the day
for this session we have a assistant
professor tis de cook he's an assistant
professor at University of Washington
Foster School of Business
he studied the combination of Computer
Sciences and capital markets research
today his presentation is about prompt
engineering and large language models so
please welcome at this
[Applause]
good afternoon everybody
thank you for that introduction uh I
guess there's no need for me to repeat
the title but I'll say it anyways for
the sake of the recording welcome to my
session going Beyond chat GPT an
introduction to prompt engineering and
larger language models
um
my name is tease and I'm as Jorge said
I'm a professor at the Foster School of
Business specifically
I am a special breed of professors
specifically let me make sure this works
turn this on yes specifically I'm a
professor in accounting
there's not many of us
but we do exist
and I imagine whenever I say professor
in accounting there probably are more
questions than there are answers with
regards to why I'm here presenting this
session today
um so I'll kind of introduce what we're
going to do first but then second I'll
give you a little bit of a background a
little bit a little bit of a peek into
what I do on a day-to-day basis which
hopefully will give a little bit more
kind of explanation a little bit more
backstory on why I'm so interested in
large language models machine learning
natural language processing data and all
of those good things okay
okay so uh what I want to do today
the basic premise of this tutorial slash
session for the next 85 minutes or so
is I want to talk a little bit about how
we can use models such as chat gbt which
I'll generally generally refer to as
generative large language models
how can we do these to kind of help kind
of do our data science work
now that is super Broad and that's super
broad because well I do not know exactly
what all of your backgrounds are I'm an
academic some of you might be academics
many of you probably are not academics
and you probably want to use models
techniques for all sorts of applications
um but the reason I submitted this uh
the proposal for this task was actually
reasonably simple where what I noticed
was a lot of people have used chat GPT
for things
I mean I'll go by the assumption that
most of you probably have or are aware
of it or have at least used it at some
point right maybe you've used it to help
with coding maybe you've asked the
coding questions maybe you've uh kind of
asked it to write an email or maybe you
asked it to write a report or maybe you
asked it to proofread something or maybe
you asked it to give you a joke
um this particular joke by the way took
me about eight tries to get one that was
halfway decent all the other ones were
absolutely terrible and I'm like that's
not really in the spirit of what I'm
trying to say here so there was a little
bit of human kind of engineering
involved before I ended up with this one
uh but what I've noticed is that most
people and myself for a long time
included
like it's you you kind of use these
things and you can copy paste into copy
paste things into the web interface well
very often that's kind of the end of it
right you're not really doing much
Beyond it
uh and maybe you have and in that case
and hopefully there's still some nuggets
here but primarily the idea is well what
can we do besides just copy pasting
things into the web interface
right what else can we use this for kind
of a data science context and also if we
start doing that how can we do that
programmatically
right because that's the whole point we
don't want to copy paste anymore
um so that's what we're going to do
today I want to kind of give you the
tools that you can uh so that you can
kind of implement it for your own
problems so that you can write a little
python script to feed things into chat
GPT and then get it back and do
something with it or do whatever with it
that you want okay and then the other
thing is hopefully by the end of it
you'll have a little bit of a better
idea of what you can do with these types
of tools okay they're not magical like
they have their limitations but there's
a lot of cool things that you can do and
hopefully by the end of this you'll have
a little bit of a sense of what that is
okay
um also before I forget the way I'll do
questions is I'll occasionally just kind
of open it up and I'll take a few
questions take a little bit of a break
and then we'll kind of move on uh I have
a little bit of a few slides but then
we'll jump into the notebook and we'll
spend most of our time in the notebook
just running through some code and you
can follow along
the instructions for that will follow in
a moment but questions will come or the
opportunity for questions will come yeah
okay so that's what we'll do
um and now the reason why I'm so
interested in this is I would say
twofold one the thing I do on a
day-to-day basis is I I'm a tenure track
Professor I do research I get evaluated
on primarily my Publications so I I
spent most of my time behind a Jupiter
notebook running code that really is of
my work okay specifically what I do is
my expertise is in textual analysis and
machine learning to analyze company
behavior in capital markets
typically not something you would think
of when you think of accounting you
might think more about like bookkeeping
or just numbers but companies disclose a
lot of narrative a lot of text too if
you've ever opened up an annual report
there's more text than there's numbers
so my research expertise is I analyze
that text
that can be an Android report that can
be social media messages that can be
earnings calls whatever a company puts
out in the world could be a subject of
interest for my type of research
um and for that I use a lot of textual
analysis techniques I use a lot of
machine learning so I spend a lot of
time thinking about that for my
day-to-day work okay and in terms of
teaching what I do is I teach python to
our PhD students
and I teach accounting analytics to our
undergraduate students
um so I also spend a lot of time
thinking about how can I make these
tools more approachable because I enjoy
using it but honestly I get a lot of
kind of rewards out of just talking
about it like telling people the cool
things that we can do and then I learned
from that in return as well okay and I
have some work on this too where last
year kind of April 2022
um way before chat GPT was a thing I was
using these models already because I
mean there's a long history of these GPT
models I say long maybe two to three
years maximum kind of starting with gpt2
and I had started to use these models
for different types of textual analysis
problems because they're really powerful
I wrote a blog post about it last year
saying hey this is a cool thing you can
do a lot of cool things with it
um got maybe a little bit of traction
but for the most part it was kind of
Niche but then chat GPT happened and
everyone including my mom knows about
what this is so there's like a huge kind
of a little bit of a Snowball Effect
going on so I recently wrote and
recently means I only put it on like the
public facing website yesterday so very
very recent I wrote a little uh article
a paper to talk about the application of
these types of models for academic
research but I mean
running a textual analysis problem in
Academia is basically the same as
running it in practice so I consider
that to be broadly applicable those two
links are there if you want to look at
them later I'll refer back to them
occasionally but this entire session
will be Standalone but I'll kind of
point out to say Hey you want more
details go watch here I'll go look here
yep so that's a little bit my background
and I submit the session just because I
thought hey I have never done a pi data
session before I find it's really cool
I'd be happy to talk about it so I
submitted it here we are
yep
okay so uh very briefly what we'll what
will we do
um I have a few slides I think I have
about five six slides that I quickly
want to walk through uh to give you a
little bit of an understanding about
what generative large language models
are
I know this is a tutorial we want to get
to the code and we'll get there and
we'll get there real soon but I don't
know kind of what your background is and
and some of you might have a lot of
experience with these models other
others might have just played around
with the web interface a little bit and
that's it
okay so I want to make sure that I don't
lose people at the very beginning so I
just want to kind of say a little bit of
like this is what it is this is how it
works and then we'll jump into the code
yeah
then we'll spend most of our time on a
little deep type example where we'll
start automating something using the
openai API so we can programmatically
interact with chat GPT and then I'll
conclude uh with a little bit of a
demonstration of Lang chain which is a
python library that allows you to do
some more fancy things with larger
language models
depending on how quickly we go through
the material that might be a quick like
a list of cool things we can do if we
have more time I have all the code
examples in the notebook and then we can
go through that too
all the materials for today are on a
GitHub repository or our in a GitHub
repository
um you don't have to open that up right
now but at some point I recommend just
make sure you have that open somewhere
because that's where the notebook
materials are that's where the slides
are all the links that I have in here I
have those links copied into GitHub
repository too so you don't have to go
painstakingly type those over just click
on the link and again a repository
um and then that's kind of all there but
I'll show that link a few more times
okay so uh I'm an accountant so I love
disclaimers that's all we do we're like
we're really good with disclaimers so
three super quick disclaimers one this
space moves extremely fast
it's very possible that what I'm talking
about today is going to be somewhat out
of date in two weeks it is just how it
is when I submitted this proposal in
February which is not that long ago uh
gpd4 was not a thing
API was not a thing The Meta Lama model
The semi-open Source model that is very
very popular not announced same thing
with the Stanford alpaca data set wasn't
a thing so when I kind of submitted this
proposal I had something else in mind
where I'm like oh you want to use
stretch EPT automatically how can you do
it then the chat GPT API came out and
like well that idea doesn't make any
sense anymore so then I pivoted so we're
just going to look at the GPT API right
kind of makes sense I tried to make
everything somewhat future proof but
it's hard to do because I don't have a
crystal ball I do not know what the
future is going to look like but
hopefully even if things change it's
still going to be helpful what we'll
discuss today yeah
uh it's also not going to be
comprehensive I'm just going to focus on
a few things that I have experience with
that I think are easy to get started
with but within 90 minutes we can simply
not cover everything and the other
caveat and that's the middle one is I'm
an academic I don't have to ever take
anything into production
like getting stuff into production can
be a real pain as far as I understand my
wife's a data scientist she talks about
it all the time I just need to get it to
run once
and then my job is over okay so that
means that I'm not going to talk about
taking these things into production some
of these things you might be like oh
that would be a real pain I feel sorry
for you but that's not a problem I deal
with on a daily basis so I cannot speak
to it
okay uh okay so with that caveat out of
the way
um I'll pause here for a quick second so
you can open this up and I want you to
open it up specifically to do one thing
that you might have to do while I'm kind
of going through these slides here which
is you don't have to install anything
you can just like there's a button there
the launch binder the launch binder
button click on that it should spin up a
little instance everything's there you
don't have to install anything you can
just run it okay so all the things I'm
going to do today you can follow along
there
the one thing that you do need to do and
this is one of those things where if I
if I would know in advance what I was
going to do I would have put this on the
website but I didn't I only really made
this session a few days ago because
that's how we do things as professors
we're never that prepared is that there
is one thing you need to do which is you
will need an open AI API key if you want
to run everything because we're going to
be interacting with these models through
the open AI API which requires an API
key The Notebook has like three steps
that you need to do to get that
you don't necessarily have to get it if
you want to just kind of follow along by
just reading it but if you want to run
it you will need that key
um
so if you don't have one already I would
recommend just go there the one thing I
will say is that
um that key if someone else has that key
they can run things on your account and
charge your credit card if you have that
hooked up in the process so you want to
be a little bit mindful of that key just
kind of treat it as a password what you
can do if you're a little bit worried
about whoever's sitting behind you
spying on your API key they're really
long so they have to be real super fast
to copy that uh you can just create one
for this session and then just delete it
afterwards so you can create multiple at
once just create one use it and then
delete it if you're paranoid okay I'm
paranoid so that's what I do essentially
we use today I'm just going to delete it
and I don't have to worry about it okay
um and the other thing is because these
are paid Services uh if you don't have
an account yet they have about a five
dollar credit that you can use the
amount of credits that were going to be
used to run the entire notebook today is
I think like 80 cents so it's really not
that big of a deal if you already have
been playing around with this and you
ran out of credits then you will need to
make sure there's a payment method
that's going to give you an error yeah
but again it's an optional thing
okay so make sure you kind of have that
ready if you want to follow along once
we get there in about let's say five to
ten minutes
um while I get some of these uh kind of
introduction things out of the way okay
I'll try to get this uh or try to go
through this somewhat quickly just
because we want to get to the code and
then I also want to have a little bit of
time to open it up for any questions
before we jump into the notebook
um okay so a few Basics right what is it
what is a generative large language
model a generative large language model
very simple it is a model that takes
text spits out text as a result that's
the simplest definition I can give you
that's how I think about it okay so the
way that works we give it a little bit
of text that one on the left where it
says prompt that's generally how we
refer to that the prompt goes into a big
model there's a lot of them out there
the most popular one or the most well
known one is chat GPT but there's other
ones too
and then what it does is it spits out
some more text
okay the text we generally call the
completion
yeah
now I did put a little asterisk there on
the input text because there is a lot of
developments going on to make this
multimodal which means you can not only
give a text you can also give it images
or audio or whatever
which I think if you think of kind of
like images that has to remember this
potential to but there's no publicly
available well there is some kind of
like experimental stuff but there's no
kind of production ready model out there
that you can currently use for that so
it will probably take two weeks before
that is there but uh it's not there
right now so I'm not going to talk about
it I'm just going to pretend that
doesn't exist but keep an eye out for it
because I think it's real cool
um and the way that this would kind of
work is think of it as in the world of
chat gbt
you were given an input in this case I
would say hey tell me a joke that the
python crowd would find interesting that
goes into the model the model will start
to predict token by token the token is
just a part of a word basically what it
expects to come after that
it's just kind of like a super powerful
autocomplete if you will
so in this case it could be like okay
well it starts with Y and then did and
then and then blah blah blah until it
does the old joke and then at some point
he realizes it's done which is kind of
an interesting mechanic I will go into
this but or I won't go into detail but
just know at some point I realizes I'm
done and then that's it
okay
um now at first glance
this is useful for a chat bot
right I mean if you think about it kind
of like a q a style thing this makes a
lot of sense you give it a thing uh it
responds back with text all looks good
with the world
but this actually has a lot of
applications
more so than you would initially think
at least more so than I originally
thought
specifically because
this kind of approach has two favorable
features one
everything happens through text
which is kind of unreal the end of first
kind of beginning if you've ever done
machine learning because you're not used
to like like if I have a machine
learning problem or not defining it
through text like I Define it through
some type of algorithm or something
right but here everything happens
through text which is actually very very
flexible as you'll see in a moment and
the second benefit is that because these
are so large and they're generally
purpose trained
they can handle a lot of tasks without
much training like if you ask Chad GPT
to do a thing or even or especially gpt4
which is more powerful it can like you
can ask it a task and it will just kind
of do it
like if I give it a piece of text and I
ask it does this text talk any talk
about programming they will probably say
yes or no like I don't have to train it
to do that it just kind of knows what
programming is and it's able to answer
that question
okay
that last bit of the you don't have to
give it any training that's really where
the innovation of chat GPT is
okay versus all the other gpts
the chat GPD model is what we call an
instruct tuned model which is it's it's
specifically trained to be really good
at doing what you wanted to do without
you having to give it examples
okay but the models itself is kind of
the same
now the primary benefit from a practical
point of view from a data science
perspective or an academic perspective
or a researcher perspective I guess is
that you can use these models as an
alternative for doing things manually or
doing things using complicated machine
learning algorithms at least that's what
I use them for that's what they
substitute in my workflow
okay they're not as good as as people I
mean it's always better to have a person
do a thing but in many cases it gets
really really close and the benefit is
it's a machine so I can have it do a
million things and it's not going to
complain
all right you have a person they get
hungry they get tired they get cranky
the model will just do it for me it will
never complain which is really
beneficial yeah
um okay so what we'll do in the example
today is these things are best to just
illustrate so the working example that
we are going to work through and I try
to come up with an example that was
seemed reasonably practical and
non-academic because my academic
examples are not really that exciting
necessarily so if this feels close to
home that I did a good job if it doesn't
I'm sorry I'm an academic I just try to
infer what people actually are doing in
real life so let's say that we're a data
scientist right and we work at a company
and the company has a mobile app
okay
um and this mobile app it has a little
bit of an issue and people have been
complaining that it's too slow
let's say that's our problem okay now we
have some magicians some developers and
they've implemented a fix
yeah they're like we fixed it like the
lag is gone the responsiveness should be
great now
and then management comes to us and they
say well hey go verify that that
actually worked
go check go make sure that people are
not complaining about something being
unresponsive anymore
okay and so what we do is we pull up a
little SQL database or we have a bunch
of Json files or whatever text files
that just has all of our customer
complaints everything submitted through
the app okay you just can imagine in the
app there's a little button that says
hey there's a problem you want to submit
some feedback you click on it you can
add a little message
right and these messages can look like
uh it's annoying when the app takes so
long to process a payment the app could
benefit from a better recommendation
system yada yada okay but the key thing
is what we are interested in is we want
to know which ones of these talk about
performance issues and which ones don't
so that we can put it in a little
appendix data frame create a little
graph and basically say hey number of
complaints that talk about performance
went up or down or what's the same
but before we can do that we have to
kind of get past this point of having a
bunch of text
yeah so that's what we'll do we'll just
kind of build a little a little pipeline
using uh the chat GPT API to go
automatically classify these as being
related to Performance issues yes or no
yeah
and what the substitutes for is we could
do it manually or we could Outsource it
which
which Outsourcing is essentially just
doing it manually but you're not the one
doing it manually right someone is doing
it manually or we could develop some
natural language processing approach or
maybe develop some type of machine
learning
now for many tasks doing either of these
is going to be slow time consuming and
or expensive
if you've ever dealt with text you might
have experienced this I experienced this
on a daily basis so I internal license
very much if you don't do a lot of work
with text then maybe this doesn't ring
as close to home but just believe me it
can get real difficult
this example not a good example of where
this is necessary because you can
probably just create a little like a
keyword list or something where you say
hey if it mentions unresponsive I
classify it as being a performance issue
or not
um but just let's just pretend that this
is a problem that we cannot solve easily
otherwise
okay I could have picked a more
realistic example but if I pick a more
realistic example I'm going to spend 30
minutes trying to get you up to speed on
what the example is and that's not the
point for today
okay so we'll just kind of like let's
say we've made the cost benefit trade
event we want to go use the glm to do
this
okay so the way we're going to do this
is we're going to develop a little
prompt which is this thing over here I
don't I maybe cannot see the pointer but
that thing on the left
which is just a piece of text that says
does the feedback mention the
performance issue that we're going to
put in it before like a little feedback
text and we're going to ask it to return
it in Json
there's nothing special about this just
a piece of text
okay this like developing that thing on
the left that's what we call Prompt
engineering engineering The Prompt I put
engineering and air quotes because if
you ever spend any time on Hacker News
people get really hung up on the term
whether this is engineering or not
some people are like oh that's
definitely engineering like ah this is
such a valuable skill now that people
are like this is people saying that
they're good at Google Googling
kind of a fair point I mean like that's
not really a thing you put on your CV
these days but people do like currently
put on their CV that they're really good
with prompts
I think people are or companies are
hiring people that are good at it
whether that will stick or not I do not
know but right now you have to like play
around with a little bit to get that to
work yeah and then what will happen is
it go through this thing and it will
give a piece of tax back in this case
answer uh equals zero and then we can
load that back into Python and do with
it whatever we want to do
okay so that's what we'll kind of
implement with a little bit more detail
uh and then in order to do that we have
to kind of do some steps which I won't
go uh through this in too much detail my
paper goes in this in painstaking
details there's many pages of details if
you want go read that but basically we
need to go figure out do we just want to
ask it to do this or do we want to give
it some examples maybe we need to do a
little bit of training
like there are some steps involved there
we're going to be in the world of
everything just works it's called zero
shot it just works out of the box that
doesn't always happen very often that's
not the case you might have to do some
fine tuning you might have to train it
that's out of scope for today there's
resources out there if you want
and then we're developer prompt right we
somehow tell it how we want to like what
we wanted to do we give it some
instruction we give it the text and we
ask it go do this thing
um this prompt engineering there's I
have a lot of resources on it they're
all in the GitHub page but basically the
high level takeaway here is that
interacting with these models it's a
weird mix of talking to a person and
talking to a machine it's really
unnerving at times because on the one
hand you're just talking like you're
talking to a human like can you please
do this I catch myself asking please or
including police all the time where I'm
like can you please do this I'm like why
am I like what is this like I'm afraid
that they're going to take over the
world and they'll spare me because I was
nice to them or something like I don't
know but it's just human nature and it's
hard to kind of or it's easy to kind of
forget that you're talking to a machine
but it is important to keep that in mind
because sometimes you ask it to do a
thing and a person would never get
confused but the model it might have no
clue what you wanted to do it would just
because straight over its head okay
um the same thing here like in this
example like I can ask it to return Json
if I ask a normal person to go like a
research assistant and ask it to give me
this and Json they're going to give me a
Blank Stare oh they're gonna be like I
don't I I have no clue right that's
going to be super tedious the model
doesn't care
curly brace equal to the model as an a
like any character is basically the same
thing
so we kind of have to figure out a way
to talk to it that's kind of like
human-like but at the same time also not
and that's the whole kind of art of
prompt engineering sometimes people call
it the AI Whispers so I'm gonna have to
get it to do what you want and it's a
kind of more of a trial and error if
anything
and then finally we want to make sure
that it actually works I'm an academic
this is what I get grilled on all the
time so but I think in practice it's
super important too you want to make
sure that it works
right I mean it's easy to just assume
hey these are powerful everything will
work but that's very often not the case
you got to check gotta make sure it
doesn't actually do the thing I wanted
to do
um okay I have some tips here I won't go
through these but this like you can look
at this later if you want to go do this
here are some tips to get the prompt to
work we'll kind of refer back to some of
these every so often the paper goes into
more detail just know there's a lot of
things you can do to have a more of a
success whenever you develop a prompt
yeah it's a little bit dry material so
we'll just pretend that slide's not here
but you can use it as a reference
material
okay so let's see how are we doing on
time here okay good uh so I'll open it
up for a few questions if there are any
before we jump into the notebook and
then we'll kind of dive into those uh
materials if there are any questions
anything you want me to go into before
we'll get into the code
I'm a teacher I spend a lot of time
teaching on zoom and if there's one
thing I know on Zoom I have to wait at
least a few minutes but there's a
question in the back yes
yeah so I'll repeat the question for the
recording or for the microphone is the
question is is prompt engineering
simpler for dpt4 than it is for chat GPT
or GPT 3.5 turbo or whatever it's called
in the API I would say generally
speaking yes I would say generally
speaking the gpt4 which is the more
powerful model it will be able to do
what you want without you having to baby
it as much
but at the same time there still is
prompt engineering involved even with
the gpt4
but for the most part it does tend to
work much better and I've noticed at
least using just the the interface if I
can do something with gpt4 that
generally works much better the thing is
it is extremely slow and extremely
expensive so for what we're going to do
today very often it's just not really a
viable option it's like many many
magnitudes more expensive
sure
yes
right yeah so the so the question it
kind of relates to sometimes you give it
kind of a human instruction it gets
really confused and then you add
something and then all of a sudden it
starts working
um I've noticed the exact same behavior
now why that is exactly happening I
think that the the most honest
explanation I can give you and I mean if
there are machine learning people in the
crowd they might disagree but I think
we're currently at a stage where we
generally don't really understand
exactly how these things work so I
cannot claim to say I kind of to know
exactly why that works but the thing I
would say
um it's kind of more of a practical
takeaway is that
I've noticed and I've interacted with
these a lot also at scale is that small
things in the prompt can make a huge
difference in the ultimate outcome
like and that can be like adding
something can make a big difference but
also sometimes just taking something
away can make a huge difference like I
used to have another kind of a use case
um and I wanted them to I think it was
like I was trying to classify Twitter
messages or something along those lines
and I had the word May in there like
it's like it may relate to something
the model just caught like all over the
place High variance I removed the word
May and I just say relates to and all of
a sudden it starts to kind of do what I
wanted to do so for some reason that
little that one word that one token just
threw the entire model off
I wouldn't be able to tell you why but
the key takeaways I guess you want to
play around with this uh and sometimes
taking things away can be useful
sometimes just super bluntly say this is
exactly what I want can help but it's
more of an art than a science
does that does that help
okay
yeah in the back
PT or TPT to create its own prompt there
are developments or experiments
currently happening that try to do this
and I think for a lot of people that say
being good at building prompts is kind
of like being good at Google Googling
it's kind of like their argument usually
is this is a temporary thing but
eventually the tool is going to get real
good at helping you write those problems
or the tool is just going to get so good
at understanding what you wanted It
ultimately doesn't matter
um I have tried this and I've had mixed
results for the most part
I've and I because I very for academic
reasons and I think this applies more
generous for all problems very often you
have a very specific thing you wanted to
do and it's very hard to communicate to
the model what you want the prompt
exactly to do
so then you're kind of back into you're
trying to prompt it to create the prompt
and then you might as well just create
the first prompt in the first place if
that makes any sense so that's kind of
my experience but there are people that
kind of swear by just having the model
create the prompt for itself and then
just kind of
use it so
I say use it as inspiration but I
wouldn't blindly rely on it yeah but it
is kind of an interesting development
okay
um I think this is a good point
to talk about it like in 30 minutes or
so to kind of set the stage here
so for the remaining time
I just want to
get our hands dirty and talk a little
bit about like how does this look like
in code okay now I'll open this up just
in case you haven't been able to pull it
up if you want to follow along
uh I have a this Repository
it's very easy to get to if you don't
want to type this whole thing out just
search my name it's easy to find
um and what I have in this repository is
I think reasonably straightforward
is the slides are here if you want to
look at it we have this notebook right
here and there is some other like
there's an environment file if you want
to download this locally you I don't
recommend you to do that now because it
will take a little bit of time to
download all of that but if you want to
at a later Point recreate this
environment you can
but for now the only thing you really
have to do is just click this launch
binder button
I don't need it but it opens up this and
then it will take a little bit of time
to kind of load but then once you do it
should just pop you straight into a
Jupiter lab where you can run your code
okay just kind of set everything up
automatically
super fast
okay
see what did I break
discover this
okay I think it's just
there we are
okay
now
make sure this is large enough for all
of you to see
is this legible enough
yeah okay good
um this notebook really really really
long there's a lot of stuff in here
we're not going to be able to go through
everything in page taking detail we just
don't have the time for it plus
I mean if I were to do that it would get
a really kind of uh tiring 90 minutes
which they're already pretty long so
I'll just kind of skip over a few things
I'll kind of highlight the things that I
think are kind of uh interesting
um I'll also stop occasionally to kind
of ask hey did anyone have any questions
anything you want me to talk a little
bit more about
but uh essentially what we'll do is
we'll start off by replicating that
problem with the um the feedback
messages for the app to try to identify
the ones that relate to Performance
issues and the ones that do not and then
after that I have I think about four
three or four different examples that go
uh or that use the Lang chain library to
do all sorts of cool stuff but the cool
stuff it gets complicated real fast so
I'll kind of take a little bit of a
higher level approach to those but I do
want to take a little bit more or go
into a little bit more detail for the
API just because I think that's where
the real power is like if you can kind
of do that then like your world the
world is your oyster basically the Lang
chain stuff might be useful but for many
of you probably is less useful than just
being able to interact with the API so
that's what we'll focus on
um if you're familiar with apis this is
probably going to be a breeze if you're
not that familiar with apis or using
apis or interacting with apis using
python some of this might be a little
bit more new but I'll kind of take it
slow and again if you kind of get
confused or you get lost at some point
once I opened it up for questions just
let me know okay I'd rather take it slow
and go through less material than to
just race through everything and then
kind of lose everyone along the way
okay
okay so what we want to do is we just
want to load this up and then hopefully
I did everything right and I can just
load this
in terms of packages in case you're kind
of curious
there isn't really too much exotic stuff
going on here the only packages that we
really are going to use is the open AI
package but the open AI package is super
basic it's basically just a wrapper
around requests so if you ever do any
API calls using requests you can do this
using requests directly too really not
that big of a difference but the open AI
Library just makes it ever so slightly
more convenient
okay so that's what we use and then
these other kind of the tech token one
we'll just use to get a little bit of a
sense of how expensive it's going to be
and the Lang chain is for all the kind
of more complicated examples later
and then we'll we'll borrow a little bit
from the scikit learn Library too so
that we can do a little bit of
evaluation just like we would with any
other machine
learning okay
okay so we can kind of run this this is
just a bunch of stuff
uh
doesn't really matter
uh this little section here is all
uncommon it but you don't necessarily
have to do that is that particularly the
Lang chain Library it does a lot of
things and it can be really opaque what
it's actually doing I find it very
helpful to just be able to see what
requests is actually making to the API
so I know exactly what it's doing which
is not super obvious most of the time so
I wrote a little a little bit of code a
little bit of script it's not super
pretty but it does work that essentially
logs all the requests to the openai
server and just stores it into a file so
I can just look at the file and say hey
these were all the requests that were
being made we won't need this for the
first bit because we're going to be
making the requests so we know what
what's in there but later on once we get
to these more complicated packages it
just does a lot of stuff and it's kind
of hard to keep track so I'll show you
what it's actually doing in terms of
requests so you can follow along a
little more easily but I didn't debug
this very well so it might very well not
work on your computer
okay so I know it works on mine so I'm
happy to run it but in your case you can
just kind of leave these uh commented
out or play around with it if you want I
mean you do you
but in my case it does kind of work but
that's what that is yeah
okay and then here these are this is
where the steps are to to get the open
AI key if you want it you can just
follow those
um you can put that in here in my case I
have it stored as an environment
variable so it just pulls it from there
for all these kind of Secrets generally
being able to store it in a file or
store it in your kind of environment
variables probably a good idea you don't
want to just have this in your notebook
right I mean if you like there's a lot
of cases where companies and this same
thing applies for like AWS or Azure or
whatever keys if you put them somewhere
on GitHub and people get access to that
they can just start charging on your
account same thing here with openai
okay so you want to kind of treat this
with a little bit of caution and don't
come running to me and say hey after
your session someone racked up a
thousand dollar bill in my account I
told you so okay so in this case I
already have it set up if you don't it
will prop up a little thing you can copy
it in and then you should be okay
and then what we'll do is we have a
little bit of data because we need to
work with a little bit of data
specifically
the data will work with is for this
first example we'll just use 20 examples
of app feedback it's very small sample
but just makes things much easier and
then for the other examples we'll use
some data that I'll talk about later
specifically I just scraped all the
talks that we'll have at this conference
and we'll build a little bit of a
recommendation system using glm using
Lang chain to predict what talks might
be interesting to a certain individual
okay so we'll use that later for now not
super important and the same thing for
this next
the the last example is that I have is
we'll allow the language model to
actually execute python code and just
control pandas data frame directly it's
a terrible idea but just for the sake of
demonstration I'll show you how to do it
okay but we'll do that at the end and
for that we need a little Excel sheet so
that's what this is
yeah also in case you're wondering this
is just a thing that I only recently
figured out I could do but I thought it
was really cool is I have a little kind
of a little function here I won't dwell
on this for too long but if you work a
lot in Jupiter notebooks this might be
useful
this one right here this little function
allows you to just print things and mark
down and have it render in a notebook
I don't I do not know why that gives me
so much joy but it gives me a lot of Joy
because I can do things like this
and I know there are ways to do this in
notebooks too but it's just a little
Philly I find it easier where I can just
have it print something and just like
put something in bold
that's what this is like the 64. it's
just like an F string right but I do the
n print instead of print and it just
renders it nicely
completely unnecessary but at the same
time it's one of those joys in life okay
at least it is for me but maybe I'm just
worth it yeah okay so
um
let's run through this example right
here
which is to automate this problem using
the openai API yeah now the data that we
work with just to kind of give you an
idea
is we have a little data frame here
where we have like this is very similar
or very simple we we have a little index
so we can keep track of it we have the
message
I mean I I generated the messages using
gpt4 so they're not really realistic
necessarily but it just makes things
easier I couldn't even be bothered to
generate 20 examples that should tell
you how lazy I am but it worked really
well I just asked it hey give me 20
examples of this and it just did it
right I mean
save myself a little bit of time and
then I also asked it to classify it at
the same time while it was generating it
so I like again don't read too much into
it but just gives us something to work
with Okay so we have our little message
that we want to classify as it relates
to Performance issues or not and we have
our little column that says this relates
to Performance issues so that we can
evaluate it
all right which that evaluation is kind
of important because if we do not have
some type of gold kind of gold standard
here or like a sample of Truth we have
no way of knowing whether it will work
and we want it to work so we have to be
critical of it and like have something
to check okay so we'll kind of feed
these predictions through and then we'll
compare it with that column to see
whether it worked yes or no
okay
um
and then we can kind of look at what
these look like
which we could have here for example a
piece of feedback that just says Hey
navigating the app feels sluggish at
times especially when scrolling through
large lists
we could have please add a feature to
create and share wish lists with friends
and family
the creativity of gpd4 is unmatched
or the app is too slow to load images
which makes it hard to browse products
efficiently otherwise it's a great app
okay
good right we have 20 of these we could
easily do this manually but let's say
that we have a thousand or ten thousand
of these I would just want to be able to
automate this and do it automatically
Okay so
this is where the real magic happens and
it has very little to do with coding but
this is where you're going to spend
hours or days or whatever it is to kind
of get this to work sometimes it works
real like real quickly in just a matter
of a few minutes sometimes this can just
be really frustrating but we have to
figure out a prompt
that's really like for the most part
that's really the only we have to do we
have to just figure out how we can ask
jet GPT to do this task
and do this task consistently
okay so what I did here is I and you can
do this just using string formatting in
Python you don't have to do any kind of
special things there are special
libraries for this but honestly it's
really not that complicated you just
create a sentence with placeholders
using curly brackets and we're just
going to slot values in as we generate
our predictions
okay
so what we have here
is we have our little prompt the prop
template it's a template Because the
actual message is not in there yet right
we're going to just slot the different
messages in here as we run it and we're
going to ask it identify whether the
customer feedback text below mentions
performance issues uh and then I can
scroll it up a little bit so I can see
the whole thing
with our app answer using the following
Json format and then I give it a little
bit of a format and then I give it the
feedback text I give it the the index so
I can keep track of it I give it the
message and then I tell it Json equals
and then we're basically just going to
give it to the model and we say hey
figure out what should come next
now when I wrote this I went back and
forth on this a few times to kind of get
it to kind of behave like this usually
doesn't work out of the box okay so a
few things that I kind of realized as it
was developing it one I realized that
having Json equals at the end is just
generally a good idea it just makes it
behave much more consistently if I don't
have that
sometimes it just goes off and does a
thing
like sometimes it just says yes like I
don't want you to say yes I want you to
say one or zero
but by forcing it to go into Json I kind
of it's like oh oh this Json format here
that probably has to go here it makes it
much easier to predict what should come
next
okay
but again I didn't know this at first I
just kind of play around with it so I
usually do this the same thing the order
matters
like I could put this message in the
very beginning
and then I say classify the message that
came first but that very often doesn't
work as well just because like because
it reads it left to right so it just
reads some random thing that I cannot
control and then it reads my
instructions but then it reads my
instructions conditional on the actual
feedback thing and then from one
feedback to the next it might figure out
that it needs to do a different thing
okay it's it's a little bit it's more of
an art than a science sometimes a little
bit black magic too but this is where
you just want to play around with it
the good thing is
you can play around with this all day
long like if you want to work with Ras
or like research assistants which I
sometimes have to do I have to ask very
nicely can you please try again
with this I don't have to ask anyone I
just Ram a bunch of API calls in there
and it just does the thing all right I
have to pay a little bit of money but as
you'll see later this will cost like a
fraction of a cent like it's is really
really cheap
okay
so what we have here is we have a little
template
okay and we can give this template to
the API call and I'll kind of show you
how that works
we do this like for example we take a
little example oh no okay I need to run
this
where again as you see here like there's
nothing special about this right I just
use the format command in Python to just
like swap in the the variables
and then we get a prompt that looks like
this
where the thing that gets swapped out is
the the index gets swapped out
you can't see there but that's right
here and we've got a little message okay
and this we can copy paste this straight
into the chat GPT web interface
that's essentially what we're going to
do but we're just going to do it through
the API
it's actually a very powerful way to
debug just take this copy paste it into
the web interface and just play around
with the Dare it's exactly the same
model
there's some asterisks there but for the
most part exactly the same model
okay
um
okay let me see I think I'll just kind
of take a quick pause here because I
think the prompt like that's really
where the magic happens the rest is just
a little bit of Nitty Gritty how do we
send this into the API how do we get it
back but does anyone have any kind of
thoughts questions on kind of this
particular prompt or anything like that
it's totally fine if it's clear but
yes
right yeah so the question uh is I
didn't put quotations around kind of the
actual feedback thing which kind of
makes sense for people but to a computer
like if you try to do an actual code
it's not going to work right like we
need to delineate it as this is a string
otherwise it's going to get really
confused
um interestingly
the quotes can make a difference for
these types of prompts because it can
help the the model understand where it
starts and where it ends but I kind of
sidestep that problem a little bit by
just adding an enter by adding a new
line character here and a new line
character is what makes it kind of
separate out where it starts and ends if
I wouldn't do that sometimes it might
get confused about where the feedback
starts or ends uh
so generally speaking you want to do
something to make it obvious where it
starts and where it ends but in this
case I sidestepped it by doing the
quotes and
very often because you you like you pay
these models by the token
they generate tokens one by one and you
pay for every token you don't pay a lot
per token but still it scales up so what
you want to do is if something is not
necessary it's generally a good idea to
get rid of it because it just makes
things ever so slightly faster and it
makes things ever so slightly cheaper
so that's why I didn't do it here but I
think you could do it and it probably
would work uh equally well yeah
binaries
so apply only with one or zero if
yes
right
yeah great point so the point being made
is that I have some redundancy here that
I probably could get kind of rid off to
kind of save on some tokens specifically
this whole I equals business maybe
that's not necessary and the same thing
with the Json equals maybe if I just ask
it to return one or zero it probably
will be just fine
in many cases in particular if you give
it some examples or if you fine tune it
I would 100 do it that way the thing I
have noticed and I'm an academic like I
nitpick over accuracy just because
that's kind of what my life is uh is
that I did notice in this case if I do
this it will like it will cost a little
bit more tokens but it gives me two kind
of Peace of Mind things that sometimes
are worth it it's up to if they're not
which one I'd like having to either
because sometimes when you send these
things it can be a little tricky to
match it back up to the original data
set if you if you coded up diligently
not an issue but this way it makes I can
just save it in the file and I can just
like completely blindly open the file
back up and I know oh that was I so that
one so I can match it up
so that's kind of why I do it because it
makes it easier to match a little bit of
redundancy the Json one it just
eliminates any chance that it starts
doing anything else which for the zero
shot sometimes it does if you fine tune
it or if you give examples not a concern
because you just basically force it to
think that way and it's always going to
do exactly what you want but I agree
with you if I was really concerned about
tokens I would just not have it do any
of that just give one or zero and it
probably would work just fine
yes
yeah so that's an interesting point so
the point bringing up is if you if you
are in the chat GPT interface right you
can have a conversation with it like you
can have and then you can follow up with
it multiple times
you that doesn't exist in the API but
the thing is it's like if you think or
if you the way that the chat GPT app
works like the web interface is it does
nothing else like it doesn't have a
memory either it just builds a new
prompt every time where it includes your
previous conversation as part of the
prompt
so you can have a memory through this
too if you want like I could have it do
this thing have a generation and then I
can do a follow-up I just have to create
a new prompt where I add its own kind of
message as part of the prompt that I
give it for the second kind of
communication
so you can build a memory but these are
all independent predictions and also
with the chat GPT interface exactly the
same thing they're all independent it's
just that it starts building up the
prompt as you go along to make it aware
of what the pass look like like they
don't have state if you
want
yeah
right
yes yeah and I have an example of that
in a moment but still it's still doing
the thing where it puts it all in a
prompt it just happens on the open AI
side of things instead of on your side
of things but it's I like to think of it
it's easiest to think of it as it's just
building one big prompt somewhere
because that's ultimately what it's
doing makes it easier to kind of
understand why it sometimes works and
sometimes does not
okay yes I'll take that quick question
and then I'll show you how to run it
yeah
in the feedback
yeah so the question is what if there's
a feedback what's there what if there's
a new line character inside the feedback
yes and that's a good question and it's
actually really interesting because
like I I've been doing natural language
processing for for many many years and
like these things matter a lot in
traditional methods like you just put it
like a wrong character somewhere and
everything breaks it's just like it's
just how it is these models have kind of
like a uh they have a little bit of kind
of a foolproofness built into it where
if I would accidentally have a like an
extra new lighting here most of the time
it probably will still work it just kind
of realizes hey this probably is all
part of the same feedback because of the
type of text that it is
what I could do is I could clean it up a
little bit beforehand and just make sure
there is no new line characters in it
before I put it into the prompt that
would be the safe way of doing it but it
actually it's much more redundant than
some other methods are just because of
what it is like it's trained on text in
the internet text on the internet is not
known for being super clean so I just
kind of learned to deal with it but I
wouldn't rely on it for anything
important yeah good point
Okay so
what we have we kind of have our prompt
right this is where you spend like this
is where real very often the magic
happens just figuring out how I how can
I put my task into a prompt and how can
I get something back that I can actually
use
usually once you figure that out there's
a little bit of a kind of like a scale
up scalability concern and a cost
concern but for the most part it really
is not that complicated anymore okay so
what we can do
is we can do the programmatic equivalent
of copy pasting this into chat GPT
um but before we do that there is one
thing that is kind of useful to think
through which is
on the chat GPT interface if you don't
have a subscription it's kind of free
right you just plug it in there and you
don't pay for anything uh if you have
the the Plus subscription or whatever
you pay a fixed fee it's not doesn't
scale variably again accountants so I
think variable cost
if you do this through the API these are
variable cost items which means the cost
scales with the number of tokens that
you give it
which for just like a little bit of
experimentation doesn't matter but
before you just start like hammering
this with thousands or ten thousand of
calls you want to do a little bit of
math and make sure hey this is not going
to bankrupt me right
um because depending especially if you
use the gpt4 API you can rack up costs
pretty quickly because that's not cheap
chat GPT API pretty cheap gpt4 not okay
so I always want to do a little bit of
math beforehand to know how much is this
going to cost me
okay the way we can do that is there's a
library called tick token it's also by
openai
and what this does is it will enable you
to essentially convert your little
prompt into what what kind of GPT will
see it's just like a vector with numbers
which represents different tokens that
are in your prompt okay and then because
you pay per token if you have an idea of
how many tokens you have you can
calculate how roughly how costly it's
going to be and also roughly how long
it's going to take
okay
so we can do that we can create a little
encoder that will encode the text to
this Vector of numbers which are these
representations for the tokens and if
you do that here for this specific
example
uh I can encode this and I can actually
just show you what this looks like
because
why not
you will see this is what what chat GPT
or GPT or whatever we'll see just a
vector just a list of numbers
but these numbers it has kind of like an
internal memory of what these actually
represent and they usually represent in
the English language about four
characters of a word
okay so like a short word might be a
single token like you can look up what
the code is for the for example like
that's just a number
um but then if you have a word that
consists of multiple words then or a
little bit of a longer word that can
consist of multiple tokens then you
might have multiple of these in a row
okay
um
there's nothing really you have to do
with this but it is good to realize that
that conversion is happening because
sometimes it explains why things are a
little bit weird
okay uh also there's a um
if you search open AI tokenizer
there's this little web interface it's
not it's not exact because this only is
for chat for gpt3 not GPT 3.5 or gpt4
but you can put like a little text in
here that says uh whatever
like if I put this in here
you will see that it will kind of tell
me what the tokens are now in this case
these are three tokens but depending on
what type of model you use it might be
split up sometimes too okay so I can I
can copy in for example this whole thing
again this is slightly different for the
chat GPT one but this is more visual
and you will see like here for example
the word identify
like and these are kind of arbitrary and
I like they're all kind of use the same
tokenizer I'm not entirely sure it
probably just doesn't matter all that
much but you can see the word identify
for example
it's kind of consistent of like ident
that's like the first token and then if
I is the second token but like in the
world of chat GPT the world of GPT
that's two kind of different things it
realizes there's a kind of like a white
space in between two so that has some
informational value but sometimes it
does kind of really weird Behavior or
sometimes you're like why does this cost
so many tokens it's just because certain
things take up more tokens than others
okay like a word can be just like one
token like following but like this whole
thing with this Json thing might be like
five different tokens because everything
is a separate token
okay like you can you can play around
like once you start scaling it up you
can be like I'm going to remove white
spaces we're not necessary because the
white space is a token too most people
are not going to be living in that world
but that's the thing one can do
okay so just kind of like that's what's
what's happening
and we pay per token
and specifically here we know so just
get rid of this we have about 76 tokens
in our prompt
um and our completion which is what it's
going to generate is going to have about
13 tokens
this is where just returning one or zero
is going to be a little cheaper right
because there's just going to be one
token versus a bunch
and then I can calculate how much that's
going to cost by just going to the open
AI pricing page there's different apis
too I'm not
affiliated with opening I'm not paid by
openai go spend your money wherever you
want to spend your money
um there's also my like the Azure has
open has endpoints for many of these
models too and you can just look up how
much is going to cost and here for
example GPT 3.5 turbo which is chat GPT
cost
0.002 dollars for every thousand tokens
okay so we can do the math
how much is it going to cost me to feed
about 20 of these examples through my uh
my little pipeline here let's say one of
these examples is about 100 tokens we
have about 20 feedback items cost per
1000 is about 0.002 dollars and then we
could do our little math here to say
running 20 items is going to cost me a
whole total of 0.004 dollars
okay so that's not really going to be
that big of a deal
at least I hope it's not because then
you probably have bigger issues
uh but we can do the math here too where
let's say I need to do this for a
hundred thousand it's all fun in games
that I can run 20. right and even if if
20 would cost me ten dollars and I'm
like oh I don't care about ten dollars
I mean if if 20 costs ten dollars
scaling it up to a hundred thousand is
get real it's going to get real
expensive real fast
okay so I generally say think a little
bit through how much you're going to
need to run do the math before you
commit all this effort into figuring out
whether you want to do it because you
can develop a beautiful pipeline it's
going to be too expensive it's kind of
pointless
right so it's best to do that that math
early
so we can do that here let's say
hypothetically we would have a hundred a
hundred thousand of these we can do the
math
and if we have a hundred thousand it's
going to cost about twenty dollars
okay having a person do a hundred
thousand of these is going to be more
expensive than twenty dollars
I would assume I haven't really
outsourced anything overseas but I would
assume it's more expensive than this
okay uh that is everything I have for
you today if you want to know more I'm
always on get up I have a bunch of Open
Source stuff so you can follow me there
uh if you want to go into more detail my
paper is a good source it goes into
painstaking details so maybe even too
much detail but you can find that on
SSRI and it's for free so you can just
go read it if you want
and then with that we were out of time
for questions I wish you a great rest of
the conference and I'll stick around if
you have any more time and otherwise
have a good evening thank you
thank you